let's talk a little bit about encryption
and specifically kind of modern
encryption and how it works now Before
we jump straight into something like the
advanced encryption standard I wanted to
talk about SP networks or substitution
permutation networks because they are
the basis for a lot of modern
cryptography not all of it but a lot of
symmetric cryptography anyway Dave has
done a lot of videos on things like
enigma anybody can take classic cipher
and it's a substitution cipher
just like the Caesar cipher it's just
for its substitution is a little bit
better than the Caesar cipher so with
something like a nygma or the Caesar
cipher you've got an input which is you
know letter one letter 2 3 4 5 this is
the message going this way and this is
going to undergo some kind of
substitution and turn it into another
one which let's say is kind of
ciphertext 1 ciphertext 2 5 2 X 3 5 2 X
4 and so on each one now there's a lot
of pollen to see this - okay and there's
a few problems of enigma but one of the
problems is but there's only ever one to
one mapping that is to say this
character is encrypted and becomes this
character and this one is encrypted it
becomes this character which means that
however complication of substitution is
to work out the mapping you really need
to focus on these two characters alone
if this cipher text was based on ten of
these characters that'll be a little bit
more difficult already so we could say
that the Enigma machine or Caesar cipher
has a block size of one right which is
but it encrypts a block of one character
into an output of one character right
now modern encryption doesn't work this
way modern encryption has a block size
it's quite a lot larger right certainly
this is a block cipher so a block cipher
is something that takes a block of a
certain size let's say 128 bits and it
turns it into an output or ciphertext of
128 bits so what I want to talk about
today was a very simple example of a
network that you can make significantly
more complicated and end up being the
most used algorithm on the planet might
not the one I'm going to show you so
this is an SP Network the idea is that
is that what we want to do is combine
some kind of substitution process
changing characters for other characters
with something called a permutation
process swapping characters around XOR
in things to other things moving things
about and that way not only do is the
mapping between the input and the output
confusing but it moves all over the
place so it's even more confusing
technically that's what enigma does
though right no yeah because every time
you change it the map you know so so the
yes a good question right so let's go
back to this
so what enigma does is it changes this
substitution if we tick but it doesn't
mean that this goes to this and this
goes to this and this goes to this so
it's still one-to-one it's just for the
substitution is confusing and changes so
it's still gonna block size of one an
Engel I guess will be better if I had a
bigger block size but I don't know how
they would wire that up what we want is
some kind of slightly larger block so
I'm going to have a full block
substitution alright so I'm gonna have
something called an S box right an S box
I'm gonna do like this takes four bits
of input so these are the bits might be
the north or one or two one or two one
or two one and it outputs four bits and
then in it I'm going to come up with
some rules so when a five goes in let's
say a seven comes out and when a
fourteen goes in a two comes down right
and I can come up with some rules so I'm
going to make up some balls now I'm not
going to draw them all in here because
I've already want to have space so this
is two to the four possible combinations
so numbers between 0 and 15 right all
zeros to all want okay so let's come up
with some rules right so for example
let's let's do all the inputs so in what
North one two three four five six
possible to this bit I think those are
all the different combinations so I'm
gonna use a different pen because
otherwise it's gonna get confusing okay
these are some rules I've come up with
now these are not particularly good
there's a lot of reasons for this one is
my xbox is too small but the other thing
is that I haven't given I mean
I've paid a little bit of attention to
things not going back on themselves but
so things like if a one went to a 10 and
a 10 went to a 1 that's kind of
invertible and that's some a
statistically weaker but if you didn't
do that right so there's a little bit
always you should be careful about when
you're designing these kind of things
right my best advice would be to use the
ones that have already been designed and
not
develop your own let's put a number
through here so let's put the number
twelve in through this S box
okay so 12 is 8 plus 4 plus nor plus
naught so 12 goes in and 12 maps to 5 so
that's going to be naught 1 or 1/4 plus
1 okay so so this comes out as 5 right
now this could be this could go into
another mess box or just some other
process right the idea is that you're
just mapping numbers to another number
now this on its own it's like a terrible
version of enigma right a number goes in
and a really poorly masked number comes
out right it's terrible because everyone
can see this
so you know what this is you can just
invert it we need more than this
ok so what we do is we also implement
some permutation so let's list this
contra permutation box a permutation box
in my example it's just going to move
things about so we're going to take
let's say an 8 bit permutation box so
that's going to be like this 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 bits of input 8 bits of output and
then we're just gonna mix it up so we're
gonna take that one over here and that
one over here this is getting confusing
I'm running out of lines okay right I
made that up so I mean you know is that
good I don't know but it's not it's not
important how good it is as a cipher so
you would have 2 X boxes here - 4 bit s
boxes for example plugging into one
8-bit permutation box so the outputs of
these get jumbled about or mixed up here
the way an SP network works is it
repeats substitution and permutation
over and over again
so I'll just draw like an example
without drawing all the lines up again
and then we'll go through using our
permutations so you might for example
have 4 bits in and another S box here 4
bits in these 4 bits come into our
permutation box and go through that
mapping which I won't draw out again but
that one right and then out come 8 bits
of ciphertext in some sense so let's put
it on belén and see how it works ok I've
got control now pick a number between 1
to 5 5 way
103 okay I'm gonna give you come about
now before I break it 103 like let me
get a pen a different pen so one oh
three oh one 100 warms wand one right
I checked because making a mistake will
be two emerging now so just do business
box on its own first right these are my
rules I've got here I'm going to refer
to them just sort of on the side this
number here is four plus two which is
six so if I look in here six goes to
eight so that's 1 0 0 0 so 1 0 0 0 like
that 0 1 1 1 is 4 plus 2 plus 1 alright
which is 7 so I look 7 up goes to 3
eventually buy naught naught 1 1 okay so
I'm gonna start trying to I mean because
I haven't drawn them in here I don't
know where they're going but this one
goes all the way to the end so this one
comes down here this one goes to that
one apparently that's not great that's
not very exciting so that's a lot this
one goes to here this one goes 1 across
to here I think I didn't I didn't
separate them out not very excited okay
I mean yeah it was mostly not that no
I'll pick a bad number date yeah it do
you not know anything about my cipher
I've got completely lost about which
number I was turning on which that that
one so one goes to there yeah okay so
there's one there one there yeah we can
cut this out and it will all look great
that one goes to there that one K so now
you would program this up so you work
quite as slow as me right because
because AES for example can encrypt at
700 megabits per second
I can't I've done 8 bits and it's taking
this way too long okay right so this
number is so 16 plus a 4 of 20 plus the
wall is 21 21 so is this a good cipher
well let's put aside the fact that it's
trivially decrypted all and say well 103
is not a lot like 21 so intuitively
maybe right it's not absolute table now
on its own this is not very good
this is called a round right and the
idea is of what you would do is you
would repeat this over and
well over again and hopefully you
wouldn't just be switching eight bits
about you'd have a whole hundred twenty
eight bit block and overtime bits from
the very left it getting moves over to
the vote right and having effects on
everything alright so this mapping
becomes much much more confusing the
other thing is that we've got to
introduce a secret key because about a
secret key if you know the code for this
you can just reverse the process this is
not hard to reverse the inverse box is
just a reverse lookup of this table and
this permutation is just a reverse
direction for all these wires so how do
we introduce a key obviously called
something called key mixing so what we
have is we have our message alright
which is the size of our block
thankfully we're gonna put it through
around like this
round one and we're gonna put it through
and - and then we're gonna get some
ciphertext now that alone is not very
good so what we do is we have our key
aisle secret key and we expand it into a
nice block of this length and we split
it up to be let's say three chunks long
right in this case and the first chunk
is ex-ored with this here and the second
chunk is XOR dear and the third chunk in
the edge sword here like this and that
means that once you take the key away
you can no longer reverses process but
the key is the secret bit we all know
how the S boxes work we all know how the
permutation box works but as soon as you
take a key away we're a bit stuffed way
if you have the key decryption is really
easy you expand the key right something
called a key schedule and you start with
a ciphertext you XOR it with this bit of
a key you go through the inverse of here
you XOR of this bit you go through the
inverse of this you excellent this bit
and you've got the message back so you
can go forward you can go backwards
all you need to do is change these light
arrows to left if you take the key away
you can't perform these XOR operations
which are going to be flipping bits and
ompletely muddling around with the input
so none of this is going to work right
you'll be able to achieve absolutely
nothing like I said what we don't do is
keep our s box or a permutation box
secret right because it will be easy to
decompile the code and work out what
happened what we do is we develop really
really good s boxes and permutation
boxes and then we introduce a key
schedule to mix our key in and then when
you take a key away you can't break it
that's how a modern s
network works you've got two rounds
there or they're usually more another
different is usually more they're not
different right so typically you'd use
the same round as usual rounds really
good the number of rounds of use will
depend on the algorithm the strength of
your round function so a EES uses
between ten and fourteen rounds the way
it's designed is that you increase the
number of rounds until you can't break
it any more
that's the idea if you use too few
mounds they'll probably be some
statistical mapping between the input
and the output
you might better work out how to break
that cipher only one half if you just
use a billion rounds then no one's going
to do anything because they're all busy
encrypting and it's going to take too
long
so you've put there's a compromise
between how many rounds you use for
speed and how many miles you use for
security right and this used in anything
we can put our finger on now this is
actually absolutely so so this SP
network is the basis for the advanced
encryption standard and the advanced
encryption standard encrypts almost
every connection over the Internet right
the one you're using now we'll talk
another time about AES the advanced
encryption standard but it functions
quite a lot like this it's just that
they've given a little bit more
consideration to their design than I
have video cycle can being applied to
every frame of an image it's gonna be
little bit noisy why you're gonna have
to take steps or tries to move that out
yet 38 billion hashes per second which
is why md5 is not usable in any sense
anymore ever don't use it okay is that
clear yet